what's going on guys this is Rob and
Carnage is about to Massacre a whole
bunch of gods now this picks up in
what's called omnipotent City and much
like what you saw in Thor love and
thunder omnipotent city is a place where
all gods across the entirety of the
universe can all come together either to
hold a kind of Congress where they all
meet in times of Crisis or to like study
books and different things like that
because all the books that are here
basically detail the histories of all
gods that have ever existed Across the
Universe now the question has to be
asked how in the world did Carnage get
powerful enough to kill all these Gods
well if you guys haven't been following
and we'll have a link to the Carnage
playlist at the end of this video
Carnage had basically started traveling
the Multiverse after separating from his
host Cletus Cassidy for the purpose of
just amassing huge levels of power and
seemingly trying to find a way to become
the new King in Black the new kind of
God of the universe so to speak and then
in turn basically wipe out all life
right as basic as it is the story was
anything but the story was phenomenal
like Carnes run over the course of the
last like two to three years has been
amazing but that's why he's so powerful
because he has none of the weaknesses of
any of the Symbiotes and all of the
strengths of the Symbiotes and then even
more on top of that and that's why he's
able to hold his own against these Gods
specifically against the Lord librarian
and the reason why is because the Lord
Librarian Is the who oversees omnipotent
city right literally a librarian dealing
with this just gigantic library but do
not let that fool you right this staff
that he holds at the tip of it that
little ball that he has it's literally a
black hole it has the ability to send
people through space and time but what's
really crazy here is that the carnate
symbiot operating on its own again
separated from its host Cletus Cassidy
has always just kind of been going under
this idea that it just wants to amass
power and so in this conversation with
the Lord librarian he literally says you
came here to learn if you are a God and
the response of Carnage is I know what I
am I have conquered every weakness of
the symbiot I have the powers of a God
the immortality of a God I have made
myself what I am and the response of the
Lord librarian here is and you come to
us for answers that you already have
asking all the wrong questions and he
says if you are a God who prays to you
who worships you what is your Doctrine
what were you created to do now this is
an incredibly important thing because
what this does is it initiates this
gigantic paradigm shift in Carnage
because he's no longer on this war path
of literally just trying to like wipe
out all of creation he's achieved the
power of a God but with this question
that was posed by the Lord librarian
what he realizes is he has all the power
but he doesn't have the role and so to
truly become a God he needs people to
worship him but it can't be one of these
things worse like the cult of Carnage
which is just like some crazy guys and
cloaks who were probably Ultra rich and
who just like want to bring him back or
something like that he needs people to
genuinely believe in him but once the
Lord librarian realizes what it is that
he's done at least seemingly comes to
this realization he literally just like
ends up snatching up Carnage using his
staff right plunges it into his chest
and Carnage is ripped through space and
time and basically sent back at some
point in his early days now the cool
thing about this is that when that
happens right he literally transitions
to Riker's Island and we're told this is
where it all began there was adrenaline
in the air then too sweet and
irresistible now one thing that I also
want to point out here is that sending
Carnage back through space and time it's
really him just kind of being sent back
to Earth is really what it is it's not
as though he's being sent back to like
the very early days of his existence
instead what goes on here is that in
this moment when he like kills this
inmate he basically spits out Cletus
Cassidy now that's one of the things
that I want to specify here right
because this can be a little confusing
if you're following the Carnage Mythos
and especially if you're not in Marvel
Comics following the king and black
event n the symbiot God and all that
kind of stuff the carnate symbiot
separated itself from Cletus and then
Cletus in turn became like his own guy
so there is a Cletus Cassidy out there
in Marvel Comics right now and you could
call him the true Cletus Cassidy right
like the real Cletus this version of
Cletus that you see here is really more
of a memory given physical form by
Carnage that's really what this is but
it allows Carnage to kind of operate and
to better understand humans at least
that seems to be the case because even
then it's a little clandestine because
all we get here is we get the statement
it takes him a moment but Cletus Cassidy
is not easily flustered he takes in the
last decade the memories seep into his
mind memories belonging to another
Cletus of another time trusting this
other Carnage holds nothing back so
basically he takes all the knowledge of
everything that's happened and dumps it
into Cletus Cassidy himself and so what
this does is for a moment it switches
over to Flash Thompson and Flash
Thompson for those of you guys who don't
really know he has at least probably
over the course of the last I don't know
decade and a half had a lot more
involvement with the symbiot than at any
time before especially when he became
Agent Venom which was really really cool
but ever since then he's really taken on
the role of what's called anti-venom so
in effect he's like a Venom symbiot that
can cure other people of illnesses
that's a relatively new development in
Marvel Comics it happened during King in
black but he has a kind of tie to
Carnage right in so far as he can quote
unquote sense his presence or at least
be able to detect some kind of changing
in the winds right metaphorically
speaking when it comes to the symbius
all this is designed to Simply say
Carnage with the level of power he has
now masquerading his Cletus Cassidy with
a whole new set of intentions shifts and
changes the game entirely because as
Cletus Cassidy is making his way right
just through the world as a whole he's
reading up on social media he's kind of
catching up on every that's happened
because it's one of these weird and
wonky things where it seems to be a kind
of memory of Cletus that hasn't been
around for a long time and doesn't
really know everything that's happening
I know it's a little wonky it's a little
weird I'm sure it'll become clearer as
time goes on but the important thing
here is he ends up making his way into a
diner and this girl named Sarah
literally just kind of like serves him
and as the two of them start talking
it's one of these things where we kind
of get this uh sort of monologue right
where it says in his hunger Carn finds
the thing he's missed the most the need
quote unquote it is human desires to
live to act to mate to kill right his
purpose overtakes the symbiot it is
beyond a bond Carnage and Cletus consume
each other they are one and so what's
cool is it's really kind of The Human
Side Of Carnage sort of taking over
right like almost like Carnage is sort
of reintroducing himself or beginning to
understand what it means to be a human
in the world and so you have this
conversation between himself and Sarah
where Sarah walks over and she asks like
what are you reading and his response is
the Bible right and she's just like oh
you know I'm sorry you know and he's
like why are you sorry right they're
just words not a God-fearing woman then
and he kind of comments and he says I
always found that to be a curious
expression God-fearing why fear your
absent indifferent God now this is one
of the things that I want to point out
here right from Sarah's perspective the
concept of God is most likely
judeo-christian since this is taking
place in the United States and
judeo-christianity is like the dominant
religion here in the states basically
from her perspective God is just a being
who exists out there somewhere beyond
the realm of human understanding and has
had like avatars that have appeared on
Earth to basically communicate his
message right Jesus as his son if you
believe in that Moses the whole nine
yards for someone like Cletus Cassidy
and for us as the comic book reader we
know none of that is true we know there
is no God of Abraham I guess the closest
you could get to that is the one above
all but there are a Mountain of Gods in
between right there's just all kinds of
beings that exist out there and so it's
one of the reasons why Cletus doesn't
really take the conversation about the
concept of God seriously because he
basically knows the reality of how the
various gods exist out there in the
world and so when he asks her like what
are you listening to she's like oh you
know it's just a true crime podcast
because for reasons beyond our ability
to understand women relax when it comes
to just stories about people being
murdered right like in all seriousness
right I mean like she just listened to a
true crime thing and so when when she
says you know I'll turn it off he's like
no no no that's really interesting you
know it's it's it's cool like why do you
listen to it and her response is it's
fascinating I suppose right it makes me
feel prepared something about knowing
what truly goes on out there now that's
an important statement for her to make
because what it does is it communicates
to Cletus Cassidy that people on some
level have a kind of six sense now the
reason why this whole kind of Cletus
Cassidy thing is important is because
even with Cletus Cassidy as a character
in Marvel Comics prior to any of this
right like it's origin story the
original like Maximum Carnage story from
back in the 90s and so on and so forth
he was always a kind of psychopath
disconnected from what it meant to be a
human being so he didn't really see or
function the way a human traditionally
would and he certainly didn't experience
fear and things like that the way people
would he was almost kind of like an
inhuman being walking around human
beings and so because of that it is in a
lot of ways kind of learning now Cletus
Cassidy is the Avatar right like it
really is just kind of like Carnage
that's experiencing all of this but it's
Carnage slowly and steadily learning
with this kind of su sense human beings
rather through Evolution or learned
behavior whatever it happens to be are
always kind of like on the lookout for
this idea that one there's something
greater than themselves and two that it
may manifest in some kind of a form I.E
human beings are primed to believe in a
God and so all he has to do is engineer
a set of circumstances that will lead
them to believe that and that's what's
so important here because even when he
leaves right like we're literally told
he feels the weight of godliness on his
shoulders but he finds he is equal to it
as the hours pass a plan forms a do
Doctrine It Feels Right This World this
world feels ready for Carnage now the
reason why this is so important here is
because in years past when it came to
the Carnage symbi he would just like
roll into a diner with like 30 people in
it and just Massacre them all and that
would be it right he would write like
Carnage Rules and blood or like Maximum
Carnage or something along those lines
but in a lot of ways the public
perception of Carnage was rooted more in
fear in relation to like Venom or like
the Green Goblin or Red Skull or Magneto
depending on what he's doing but it was
really just more like man I hope that
guy doesn't attack me but they didn't
really see him as some kind of Godlike
being they just saw him as like a dude
over there who does some stuff and so by
embracing this kind of Godly concept
what he can do is start to mold societal
perception of him away from this idea
that like Carnage is a guy who's violent
and tears things up and almost see him
as this kind of immutable indestructible
Force force that exists out there I.E a
Godlike being so the first person that
he targets is a guy named John and we're
told John never left the war right if
you were to ask him about his friends
he'd list the names of dead men right
he's a coward he couldn't end at all but
didn't have it in him to move on either
and so Cletus Cassidy quote unquote
grants him the mercy that God would give
him by helping him finish with all his
living in a pretty brutal way following
that he goes after a guy named
then he goes after a guy named Matthew
right and it says they all die one by
one they all die alone and no one cares
and then at that point we switch over to
a guy named philli right we're told that
when he was 19 he took a weapon to the
local gas station and did a whole bunch
of people in including his ex-girlfriend
and injured nine folks along the way and
it says he intended to basically die in
the process and that he was going to
sacrifice his life to prove that it
mattered but what ends up happening is
Cletus appears and really unlike the
other people that he went after this is
really kind of the first person that
sees him almost as a God because Cletus
approaches him in that way right like he
asks him have you found God in here and
this guy says I was trying to and Cletus
says then let us pray and so like they
literally sit down together and Cletus
is like the Forgiveness of our
trespasses according to the riches of
his grace amen he says a prayer with him
and then takes the guy out and so it's
one of these things where whether or not
it's building a kind of ideology whether
it is something akin to people who
happen to hear this and then once they
get in there they realize this person's
dead we don't fully know right because
it's hard to build a religion around
people who are dead and can't really
preach your gospel so exactly how this
unfolds I don't entirely know but one of
the things that is important to point
out here is that in relation to Gods
gods are powered by prayer it's one of
the things that Jason Aaron established
in his run on Thor right that like Gods
being powered by prayer especially when
it came to gore the god butcher a God
that no one prays to is a god who's
powerless and easily defeated and so
seemingly even if Cletus Cassidy is
taking all these guys out the very fact
that they believe in him seemingly
bolsters his power even further at least
that's the conclusion that I would draw
here and so what he end up doing is
going after this guy named Nathaniel
who's basically just like this giant
Tech Mogul but he kind of t wants him
right he says like don't you know me do
not fear for I am with you right he's
just kind of quoting gospel here right
passing himself off as a sort of God and
where Nathaniel doesn't necessarily
understand what's happening the response
of catus is you know we all think we're
special it is a staple of Western
Society the only way to Bear it right
thinking you're special thinking that
you might make it and it's one of these
kind of social criticisms to a degree
right philosophically there's all kinds
of Roads you can go down here right this
kind of argument that with Western
Society existing the way that it is you
I everybody else the only way we can
really make it in the world it's by
thinking that there's just something
unique about us that will sort of give
us the edge over everybody else even if
it's not true right lacking that belief
sort of saps your will to live again all
kinds of moral and philosophical
arguments to be made there and he says
but you you are special not because you
are if anything all the wealth and fame
and all this
this is the best that you can do right
you're nothing but a missed opportunity
in a $112,000 suit he says no you are
special because the world believes
you're special and sometimes belief is
all that matters and that's really a an
important sticking point here right like
the world believes you're special
therefore you're special there's nothing
out there that makes you special right
it's not as though you have the ability
to fly it's not like you can alter
reality it's not like you're a an angel
that fell from heaven and landed on
earth and the whole world accepts it as
an absolute truth the reality here is
that you are special just for no other
reason than the fact that people believe
you are for whatever reason you've
convinced them that that's true and so
what ends up happening here is you get
this monologue right where it says one
can say much about human indifference
but when presented with something they
do not understand they rarely think the
worst and so this kind of like uh cloak
right this just sheet comes down off
this giant box and like Nathaniel's in
it right it's got these little holes in
the bottom and it says they do not see
the horror in front of them for what it
is they wonder what he is selling today
what publicity stunt the tech
billionaire is up to this time because
from their perception it's what this guy
does so they're just kind of basing
their decision-making and their
observations on what they already know
about him right and then what we end up
getting is the statement it is a painful
death
in progress before anyone understands
what they're looking at as water turns
to blood the boiling liquid dissolves
his skin so literally this guy is
cooking alive right as the water is
coming in just boiling water is filling
up this tank and it says they do not
understand that they are watching
warship streamed and documented
scripture in the making and so it's this
really really cool moment because what
Cletus is doing here is building up this
profile and if you notice on his chest
it's number 12 and that's the important
thing here because with each one of
these people that he's taken out he's
put a number on their chest and so what
will happen is likely the news will get
a hold of it they'll give him some kind
of arbitrary name but people will start
to realize there is this enigmatic
omnipresent Force that's going out there
and no one is Untouchable from a prison
inmate behind locked doors to a guy who
was inside his home that fought in a war
that if anything should be able to
protect himself and couldn't to a tech
billionaire with all the money and all
the resources in the world right like
it's one of these things where it strips
all of that away right like with this
guy Nathaniel for example where were all
his billions to protect him from Carnage
right what was his Fame doing to protect
him it was all intangible it was all
things that just kind of exist out there
in The Ether and that's the point that
Carnage was making you are special
because people believe you're special
which means now if you are dead people
will believe you're untouchable and
they'll believe whatever touched you
must be some vastly powerful thing to
touch an Untouchable man so it's just
one of these really really cool elements
with his character because as that
happens of course Flash Thompson kind of
transforms into his uh anti-venom suit
to basically go after because he
realizes this is Carnage right Carnage
has returned in some capacity and
Carnage is the one doing all of this but
for all the people watching it and all
the people observing it it's one of
these things where they're like God this
is mind-blowing this is crazy but from
Flash's perspective right flash knows
what he is looking at it is an
announcement an invitation it is Carnage
it is Cletus Cassidy welcoming us to
church the game has changed ladies and
gentlemen and this is one of the coolest
Carnage stories that I think I've ever
read with that being said guys're going
to bring this to an end if you need to
get caught up on Carnage make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later peace